a very good afternoon good to have you
with us we start with breaking news and
the family of missing mother of two
Nicola bully have issued a statement via
Lancashire police saying they believe
the Public's Focus has become distracted
from finding her and more on speculation
about her private life here's that
statement in full
Lancashire police released this in the
last few moments as we approach the
three-week anniversary of Nicola bully
going missing on Friday the 27th of
January we remain committed to doing
everything we can to find her our sole
Focus throughout the investigation has
been to find Nicola to bring her home
and to support her family through the
trauma they are experiencing the most
important person in all of this is
Nicola Nicholas family have asked us to
issue a statement from them the family
said it has now been three weeks since
Nikki went missing we as a family
believe that the public Focus has become
distracted from finding Nikki and more
about speculation and rumors into her
and Paul's private life as a family we
were aware beforehand that Lancashire
police last night released a statement
with some personal details about our
Nikki although we know that Nikki would
not have wanted this there are people
out there speculating and threatening to
sell stories about her this is appalling
and needs to stop the police know the
truth about Nikki and now the public
need to focus on finding her
due to the perimenopause Nikki suffered
with significant side effects such as
brain fog Restless sleep and was taking
HRT HRT to help but this was giving her
intense headaches which caused Nikki to
stop taking the HRT thinking that they
may have helped her but only ended up
causing this this crisis
public Focus has to be on finding her
and not making up wild theories about
her personal life despite what some
media outlets and individuals are
suggesting we are being updated daily
and receive support from our family
liaison officers Nikki is such a
wonderful daughter sister partner and
mother and is missed dearly we all need
you back in our lives Nikki we hope you
are reading this and we know that we
love you so much and your girls want a
cuddle we all need you home you can
reach out to us or you can contact
missingpeople.org dot UK don't be scared
we all love you so very much
well that statement follows criticism of
the police for revealing details of
Nicholas struggles with alcohol in their
news conference yesterday they explained
why they had treated her as a high-risk
missing person after her family made
officers aware of what they call
vulnerabilities
I'm not going to go into the details of
those individual vulnerabilities I've
asked you to respect the family who are
going through unimaginable pain and
distress at this moment
put those vulnerabilities based are
decision making in terms of grading
Nicola as high risk and have continued
to form part of my investigation
throughout
well hours later after that press
conference the force then put out a
written statement giving more details
regarding those vulnerabilities in a
statement it read it is clear from
speaking to Paul and the family that
Nicola had in the past
suffered with some significant issues
with alcohol which were brought on by
her ongoing struggles with the menopause
and that these struggles had resurfaced
over recent months as a result of those
issues a response car staffed by both
police and health professionals attended
a report of concern for welfare at
Nicholas home address on January the
10th no one has been arrested in
relation to this incident but it is
being investigated it went on it is an
unusual step for us to take to go into
this level of detail about someone's
private life but we felt it was
important to clarify what we meant when
we were when we talked about
vulnerabilities to avoid any further
speculation or misinterpretation